totò è messo sfondo no totoro sbagliato
video bene a tutti ragazzi di venuto
questo video sono fatti genio ci siamo
trovati su treni sono tornati ragazzi su
granny perché nell'ultimo episodio sono
morto però purtroppo c'è se come potevo
fare molto meglio
era veramente a un passo da fare
veramente meglio giochiamo giorno
ragazzi allora per chi non avesse visto
il primo episodio guardatevelo prima ci
risvegliamo in questa casa ci sono
granny e grand pas che sarebbe il nemico
numero due celle nonno va bene ho
trovato nello scantinato una barca il
che è veramente incredibile giuro che
qua sotto e questa barca qua ti permette
di fuggire prima che mancano dei pezzi
ne ho trovati soltanto ma cosa c'è un
polipo che ancora non ho capito
vabbè ho trovato soltanto due pezzi
nell'ultimo episodio
devo cercare di trovare veramente tutti
i pezzi così dice il volante ce ne
stanno due dietro che mi mancava tipo lo
spark blog così come si chiamava spark
plugs e non so come si trova sta roba
qua però vabbè lo troveremo di sopra le
righe siccome ragazzi gli oggetti di
grandi sono randò mitch così come la
posizione di loro due
dipende dove si trova la roba non si
trova sicuramente dove si è trovata
nell'ultimo episodio non c'è nessun
oggetto ragazzi dove sono sparato che
sfiga sono tutti al piano di sopra
vedete che so gioco va veramente a
fortuna perché dipende dove ti sparano
gli oggetti quindi devo venire qua per
forza granny ancora poco non si è vista
quindi meno male apri cassetto devo
trovare il taser ragazzi per trovare il
taser di nuovo devo trovare il piede di
porco che l'ultima volta non mi ricordo
manco dove era l'idea era di sotto ci
avevano avuto avevo trovato subito devo
sperare veramente iddio che che gregni e
grand pas non spuntino all'improvviso
sto guardando da dietro perché sono non
so piu come uscire allora qui ora che la
non ci sono oggetti cioè non c'è né
marco volo stavolta non è possibile ma
dai ma non c'è manco un oggetto c'è
proprio incredibile tia volta lavorati
mille fino a qua adesso neanche uno noi
chiave quadro locke key padlock 18 per
aprire il caso del della barca gregni
sta andando risotto ok grace non è vero
ti prego non è andata bene allora se
faccio gironi e scuola andare di soprano
la la chiave l'altro non è vero non ci
credo
no ragazzi ma circondato non ci voglio
credere ce l'ho fatta ma se vedete come
ho fatto
allora aspetta che gremiva fa il giro ed
infame che la chiamerei la chiave andata
risotto domanda di sopra con ricordi
cori vai glock e aprì tutto apri tutto
elettorale il taser devo trovare pieni
porta in realtà che non ho idea di dove
sia
no ragazzi mi sto pagando duramente
sotto vai apri tutto apri tutto veloce
veloce la chiave del padre ecco questa è
la carolina glielo lanciati testa datte
foco aiuto
apri la porta alle 18 18 veloce
bellissimo ma non mi puoi trovare
ragazzi ho trovato la chiave
ma veramente ma con me ma come ha fatto
porca vacca gran più intelligente di
grandi non l'avrei mai detto grandi nomi
beccava quando sotto il letto è ancora 4
vino tre vite o la chiave del pad locke
quindi quella che serve per aprire il
corso col lucchetto di sotto e la
gasolina mi mancano due pezzi per la
barca e posso fuggire e il gremio
sbadigliato demoni ma timidezze che se
devo avere una sfida incredibile che non
c'è manco ma neanche un oggetto di sotto
che sfiga abnorme
ok la chiave del padre che qua
innanzitutto io a prendere ma neanche
sarà la jolie la gasolina la prendo e la
butto giu ok ragazzi allora ho due
oggetti su quattro per fuggire due
mancano il volante e il coro è
velocissima come mi sono salvato meno
male ma come ho fatto
come ho fatto ad accorgermene va bene mi
mancano il volante e lo spark plug l'ho
visto all'inizio è teoricamente posso
fuggire da qua sotto perché immagino che
la chiave del lucchetto serve per aprire
il cancello alla famiglia ed ere e si
apre i cancelli
esatto proprio questo ragazzi allora
mancano due pezzi della barca io ho
vinto
cioè non soccorrere with no ragazzi
incredibile cioè mi stai veramente
seguendo tantissimo ma cosa è successo
non puoi parte l'hanno fatto che se ne
frega del polipo non una parola o sono
morto
madonna vaticano manganellata come tu
sorella morta
porca vacca sono morto ragazzi non poter
più salire giuro non potevo più salire
ok apri l'armadietto che forse qui muori
perfetto
riprendi subito il colpo subito subito
il colpo veloce bravo troppo troppo
tutto prendi la chiave del giallo al
nonno la chiave e veloce la chiave la
chiave madonna la chiave
l'ho presa ok corrivi sopra corri corri
corri corri corri corri cori perbellini
sono ragazzi fatto una cosa incredibile
allora volante subito e l'altro pezzo
devo correre prima che si risvegliano e
col volante veloce speriamo che non si
siano rialzati gestito due minuti e non
sono passati due minuti
non rispondo non so come sia possibile
che non sono passati due minuti la nonna
no
il volante cielo non l'avevo considerato
uno scherzo aspettare tutto qua ok
teoricamente manca solo lo spark blog
che un pezzettino piccolissimo e poi ho
preso tutto prendi la pistola per l'amor
di dio e ora devo trovare il pezzo per
sparare che non mi ricordo dove allora
gremita sulle scale quindi sarà sulle
scale dov'è il pezzo per sparare
maledizione coppa così una scala è
possibile
posso andare insomma veramente cosa c'è
ragazzi quali sopra scusato in inter c'è
un piano ancora di sopra ma come ma con
sesto posto dall'altro qua non ci
possono passare i pegni porco
eccolo no bocchi la chiave della barca
c'è ancora un altro pezzo bakroman
madonna c'è ancora ce l'ha pure la
chiave della barca madonna in tromba
come è possibile allora troppa è la
chiave della barca proprio impossibile
non sapeva che esistesse
ti prego non ci poi non puoi impiegarmi
un inventario per questo oggetto porco
demonio
lascio un armadietto incatenato però mi
manca lo sport plaghe ragazzi è l'unico
pezzo che mi manca e c'è un piede di
porco potrebbe esserci lo spark plug
nella nel disincastrato potrebbe esserci
uno sport plug in nella cosa di nella
scatola all'inizio se c'è lì ho vinto
c'è il nonno qui sotto proprio perfetto
un tempismo che guarda non ti dico
scendo pian piano gli sparo perfetto no
no no no ma che sfiga ma in tutti i
posti due potenze di bolina e posso
morire solo pista o tutto perché secondo
noi ragazzi lo spark plug e qui cui
quindi devo spaccare questo col piede di
porco per ai tempi di per quest'opera
come faccio a prenderlo devo tornare a
suo e tornare giù impossibile
ok non c'è nessuno ok
dai ti prego no che sfiga che sfiga
tremenda aprì la porta aprile ok 9 la
pistola li no non sono morto ragazzo è
morto morto morto morto suo morto come
partito morto sotto il letto non sono
morto forse madonna meno male ragazzi
meno male mi sono salvato alla fine però
ragazzi la casagrande cia tra i piani
per court quattro anzi cinque se
contiamo le fogne andate in giro se io
vado nella stanza della sicurezza prendo
la pistola
io ho praticamente se me la gioco bene
ho vinto perché io li spendo tutti e due
e poi corrono a mettere tutte e due i
pezzi
devo solo ed esclusivamente arrivare
nella stanza della pistola solo quello
cava che ci ha piazzato popolata
l'apparato la mia inter e voce porco
demonio visto la pistola pistola pistola
prendi la
no non sono riuscito a spararli dai
ragazzi che sfiga sniper ma non lo
voglio vedere ragazzi all ultima vita
impossibile quello che devo fare
veramente non so come farlo cioè dove
andare su però su ci sono loro
impossibile se vi giuro dovrebbe
raggiungere l'ultima stanza però non lo
fosse ragionevole se c'è grandi davanti
sono morto insomma e non mi posso fare è
morto vabbè ci abbiamo provato ero
stavolta era ancora più vicina avevo
tutto da solo scendere solo che chissà
perché in campo proprio in quel momento
il culo abbia fatto il passo al polipo
stavolta ma teste di culo
[Musica]
ma ti pare che io sono morto veramente
ci avevo tutto perché lo spark lei era
lì lo so ragazzi mi mancava solo un
pezzo
porca vacca che è il vostro animaletto
domestico comunque questo va bè ragazzi
ci proverò un terzo episodio peccato
perché stavolta far cavalcherà pertanto
così dovevo solo prenda visto le sparare
a grand pas e poi sparare subito no
magrelli fa e basta avanti e indietro
due volte ce la facevo per quelle due
volte e avevo tutti i pezzi finito ai
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
iscrivetevi al canale cacciate il
bellissimo tasto mi piace oltre
iscrivervi al canale e schiacciate alla
campanellina vicinato iscriviti per
rimanere aggiornati se noi video che
escono e noi come sempre ragazzi ci
veniamo ad un prossimo video bello
ragazzi
[Musica]